from a firm in apple to paypal and zip
buy now pay later transactions are
currently estimated to be at least 100
billion annually a figure that analysts
say could skyrocket within a few years i
think a lot of the rise of it is people
leaning on it just like they would for
credit cards or other times where they
find themselves a little tight on money
nathan grant with moneytips.com says
typical bnpl consumers are younger
primarily gen zers and millennials using
these services to split a purchase into
four or more installment payments over a
period of a few weeks or months they're
typically offered with zero or minimal
interest and often come without a credit
check
now while other household debts such as
credit card spending and auto loans is
gathered and tracked by the federal
reserve by now pay later data is not
included because the financing is
typically provided by non-bank sources
you're not getting any benefit from that
either there's no you know those
payments aren't helping you out they're
not being reported to your to the you
know experian and trans union so you're
not
seeing your credit reports reflected in
a positive way despite its rapid growth
some experts worry users could get into
debt fairly easily without realizing it
as with anything grant suggests you do
your research
i'd say just like any other financial
agreement you get whether it's a credit
card a loan uh or which these are you
know short-term installment loans you
want to read the fine print make sure at
least you know everything into the three
major credit bureaus have said they'll
start including buy now pay later
activity on credit reports but they
still need to rely on the providers for
that information meantime the consumer
financial protection bureau plans to
address these concerns and expects to
publish its findings later this year